CBS News has learned about a potential
terror threat ahead of the election
sources say that US intelligence has
alerted Joint Terrorism Task Forces that
al Qaeda could be planning attacks in
three states for Monday that as you know
is a day before the election is believe
that New York Texas and Virginia are all
possible targets the credibility of the
intelligence has not been confirmed
Jeffrey gazes in Washington with new
details Jeff it's very disconcerting to
hear this on this Friday good morning to
you good morning US authorities are
taking this threat seriously while still
assessing the credibility of the
intelligence but counterterrorism
officials across the country have been
alerted out of an abundance of caution
law enforcement sources tell CBS News a
threat comes from al Qaeda and
intelligence points to attacks taking
place in New York Texas and Virginia but
the threat information provided no
specific targets for possible attacks in
those states as Election Day approaches
federal law enforcement is planning for
several worst-case scenarios earlier
this week an alert to local police
warned of polling places being seen as
attractive targets for lone wolf type
attacks by individuals motivated by
violent extremists or sovereign citizen
activity a senior FBI official says the
bureau is working closely with the
Department of Homeland Security and
other federal state and local agencies
to disrupt and identify potential
threats it is not unusual for there to
be an increase in the volume of threats
leading up to significant events like
holidays or even an election an official
says it is important to investigate
those threats thoroughly Anthony Jeff
Pegues thanks Jeff